all right here we are at 5 14 on your
Wednesday morning and now I'm proud to
be the MC for tonight's second annual
nighttime block or night in white to
raise money for and awareness of one of
our eight news now Community Pride
Partners the collaboration Center
Foundation
the president and CEO Linda touche it's
benefiting the individuals family
members and caregivers with intellectual
Developmental and physical disabilities
of all ages at our magnificent five acre
ranch campus at last year's first annual
event a red carpet welcome yummy food
from some of the community's best
restaurants started a great evening that
included jaw-dropping entertainment in a
comfy outdoor setting we honored Linda
Smith one of the founders of Opportunity
Village who now has the non-profit
Christopher Smith foundation and this
year we are honoring the beautiful and
amazing Michelle de Rocher I am so
excited
over the moon over the moon we're over
the moon for you too Michelle and for
your family so also being honored Dana
blackhurst and former Las Vegas mayor
Jan Jones blackhurst promises to be
another great evening 8 news now proud
to count the collaboration Center
Foundation among Our Community Pride
partners